hey it's 72 welcome to another one of my
favorite gig to our review a website
today it's a repeat customer I'm looking
at this is josh felbarr he has josh
fabric on what you did a review of today
I'm looking at another one of his
websites primal life organics com so
let's check it out and see what kind of
advice we can give primal I forget Ock's
primal life organics paleo skincare i
love this here at the top organic
gluten-free handcrafts fresh rican
skincare I know what these guys do this
is this is I was looking to Josh website
the other day and I didn't know what his
website was all about to like dug deep
this one right away I know what this
company is all about which is great so I
saw a picture on here lets you can go
back so here are I guess two founders
beth w Trina Felber aha felber the
Felber connection and go hold on who do
I miss Carrie p promote color specialist
so this is great so my first thought is
is answered right here why paleo skin
care what the heck is paleo skin care
that's my first thought but maybe it's
answered below to let's to it we got
this sign up for our newsletter this
could be way better this is going to get
missed for sure it's going to get missed
nobody's signing up through here Josh
did better with job on his site where he
had this big chunky thing on the side
this should be made bigger and show me
the value but so far I love the top
welcome to primal F organic gluten-free
vegan skincare twenty twenty first
century cave men and women I love that
organic skincare and promo products with
natural greetings our primal ancestors
could have used for their own skincare
cool 21st century caveman is subjected
to unique environmental elements and
stressors and the service organics and
carrot is not add any toxins or
chemicals directly to the body is it
with the perfect balance and physical
vitality I love this position around the
cave man cave women these two sentences
are kind of opposite for me now you're
talking about it being something that
our caveman ancestors could have used
and then saying in the next sentence
that the 21st century caveman is
subjected to unique environmental
elements that deserve organic skin care
so how is it unique it was something
that the other people could have used as
well I love this caveman positioning
though this could just be made tighter
and pull me in a little bit more paleo
skin food this is a creative bunch
behind this made freshman order in small
batches some cold-pressed organic oils
okay so what I'm missing here is why
paleo right so that was my first
question I said no it is here when I
didn't see it then I might have missed
it I'd love to see it here likewise okay
something that cavemen great marketing
awesome why why Paley and why is this
important so let me see if I click on
here why paleo well I choose paleo I use
organic there must be safe right most
like the answer is no this is awesome
this is awesome right this could be on
the homepage don't let people have to
dig deep here what is paleo Stone Age
diet hunter-gatherer diet Peter the skin
care skin care is made with real food
sources sources our ancestors good
reviews okay strong its commercial
skincare great this could be condensed
and put a little bit on the homepage I
love this part here feel free to contact
us at support this isn't a link so
ideally we can make that a link if you
have any questions we love to help and
we love the heal naturally this is great
this seems really friendly and I bet I
bet the founders what was her name again
the wife let me see Trina I bet treena's
a super friendly person this gives me a
feeling right I feel like it's a warm
company that I want to do some business
with i would probably put a picture of
Trina here in the support and what makes
a difference for me is a lot of people
say this I can you feel free to contact
us if you have any questions that's
corporate kind of standard but we love
the help and we love the heal naturally
just that one added sentence adds a lot
more feeling to it and I feel a lot
warmer towards the company again make
this a link i can click on and and have
a picture of trini here so i know who is
behind this
I'd also love to see that warmth this
warmth brought more into the rest of the
content so you have some fun elements to
you guys with the cave woman and all
that stuff and I love to see that warmth
come in here so make each section a
little warmer a little more fun on top
of answering the actual questions that
people have and again put some of this
on the homepage because that was my
first thought when I went through it so
we've got a book we've got some packages
got some products here at more products
dirty poo primal hair wash dirty mouth
primal package you might want to test
those names um it's funny but I don't
know people would want to put dirty poo
in their hair maybe I'm wrong maybe
that's the best seller people love the
dirty poo stuff okay well let's keep
looking and see what else is on this
site so I still with your social media
all social meet us here on the side so
let's look at social media and let's
look at some more pages let's check as a
lot of stuff here let's check out the
about us let's check out let's check out
their affiliate program mmm what else
let's check out anything at the bottom
here blog posts let's check out the blog
and start with that okay so Facebook so
we've got 30 thousand likes 353 people
talking about it you know what this kind
of tells me is there was some you know
shady things going on here to get likes
to the page or the stuff isn't super
engaging so I'd work I'm really getting
the content up a little bit in the
engagement I love some of this stuff
this is something that i would probably
subscribe to any way you know talking
about organics and living a healthy
lifestyle
so looking down so we see you know
here's here's some products here's some
ancient information and some promotional
stuff cover photo but okay this is
important this is really important guys
for those are you doing Facebook
campaigns look at the difference okay so
we've got we've got three posts here
okay this one is talking about major
screw-up so it's an article okay an
article that is of interest to the
audience you got 46 people liked it okay
great you've got you've got a
promotional picture from an event only
14 people liked it why because it's only
about the company about the founder but
nothing that's adding value to me and
then I go down and look at this one here
it's personal it's showing the founder
she's talking about what she's doing 187
people likes it so you're adding value
you talk about you know you don't
believe in commercial sunblock on and on
you're adding value and you make it
personal and the stuff takes off okay
these are the kinds of posts you want to
put more of N and especially because the
founder is so personable and nice and
friendly and easy to get along with the
least from an online perspective let's
go to Twitter which is on the new
profile it's great so she's retweeting
stuff while lots of retweeting stuff
lots retweeting stuff sharing some
articles lots of retweeting some
dialogues okay I mean most important
thing is that it's uh it's current is up
to date again the numbers look a little
a little skewed you know looks like
something was happening here to get
people to subscribe and follow but
there's not as much engagement activity
right these this should be higher she
had more conversations into that many
followers but I mean the most important
thing is that people are discussing with
you they're sending tweets back and
forth and that is up to date we've got
this was the blog I think right this is
our blog now this is interesting the
blog goes to a different website
cavegirl skincare I always recommend
having a
in the same website as the major website
as your home you know your main domain
because you build so much work into
creating links and building up a profile
that you don't want to split between two
sites so i would pick one either go with
primal life organic so it goes cape
gross skincare this one is a little bit
easier to remember and have everything
forward over because when you do that
it's so much easier to get new pages
rank to get traffic going to the site
instead of trying to own two domains and
split your time between them this is
cool so here she's talking about
importance of quality proteins I wonder
if it's just skin care or just overall
healthy living means was approaching how
important she was wisely so diet so
she's talking about more than just skin
care which is great right if you guys
live the paleo lifestyle and part of
that is the skin care you're going to
attract a lot more people because
there's a lot more people who are in the
paleo as a diet then there are two the
skin care and if you start talking about
that stuff and sharing your experiences
you'll be able to convert them into
signing up for your your skin care
products as well what I would love for
this so I'm slowly getting to this I'm
not quite paleo that that's maybe a
little too radical I don't know for me
right now but I'm looking at a lot of
organic stuff and you know what the
world is overwhelming it's overwhelming
the amount of information content out
there and nobody has made it super easy
to get started so if you're looking at
being an advocate for paleo I love to
see here the top you know five ways or
steps to get into it to take somebody
who's your average American meat-eating
overweight diabetic heart disease prone
behemoth and turn them into a paleo
super healthy superfit crossfit trainer
or whatever give me the steps give me
the 10 steps or seven steps or whatever
it is to make it easy give me a system
to follow because the information I'm
telling is overwhelming this is a blog
that I might even subscribe to though
it's interesting so I love this
the content sharing recipes sharing
experiences makes it personal again keep
it on the same website and again I'd
love to see that way to you know step it
out and make it easy for me to become
paleo about us we make skin care that
will improve your health so you see this
is something that was missing on on his
page so we look at this here right I
look at this I see a wallet text I see
this picture and I i skim over this
whole thing because it's just too much
text this column is way too wide make it
more narrow make the text paragraph
shorter and have something else that's
bold that stands out this stands out we
make skin care that will improve your
health boom it hits me that's what I
understand so you got to make these
easier to understand too okay about me
so this is great trying to fill ver I
love the picture I love the smile my
roles include write something people can
relate to there's a family picture
there's the husband and the kids I love
it it's great again one thing that you
might want to add is a video why you
started this website why you started
getting into this paleo skincare the
video makes it personal makes me relate
to you a little bit better than just
showing pictures but alrighty this is a
way better start than most people have
this is just how you can get to the next
step so this is the affiliate program or
in a five percent commission for you
till you refer so it's a pretty basic
system looks like it's just been skinned
logo at the top and this is the typical
referral website by Omni star okay and
then what is important to primal life
organics so this is this is also a blog
okay now I'm confused because this says
blogs worthy i thought that other post
was a blog to about the cave cave girl
whatever it was um okay so i would have
one site one main source where you keep
all information is this is this the blog
there's the other one the blog this is
also
really short so you want to make sure
this is uh this is you know a little
more dense the other articles were
better maybe this is just being
transitioned over this is this was the
most recent blog post and it was October
23 2013 we're now looking at mid May
2014 so maybe this is being phased out
and that's a mistake on the site but
overall I love the site again the
homepage has a great job there's a lot
of the heavy lifting and makes me
curious makes you want to learn more the
design is pretty nice it's appealing I
love the pictures and the founders and
the friendly talk to make it again
summarize some of the easy things to do
to make it easier talk about the paleo
the movement why it's important earlier
on the homepage make me feel something
make the text easier to read shorter
columns more bullet points more sub
headers use more of your fun language
your creativity in the in the marketing
copy and tell me more about the the
founder your personal story have some
videos if you can keep sharing your
content make it super easy to digest and
consume for people but overall great job
and I'll probably be back checking it
out so thank you for watching everybody
if you guys have have some thoughts to
share for Trina I'm sure she'd love to
hear it leave it in the comments below
let her know what you think about her
website and for everybody watching me
like the video thumbs up below click on
my face to subscribe to the channel
thank you so much and I'll see you soon